retrouvez une ligne fine et en sept
jours seulement moi en une semaine j'ai
perdu trois kilos perdus mais à moitié
avec la coeur j'ai perdu 15 kilos bah
moi j'ai perdu 200 balles alors pu ça
m'a filé des boutons qu'une fille tout
le monde se fout de ma gueule à
l'aquagym
et c'est à paris que nous retrouvons
nacera pour sa journée shopping 1 eva
tape chrono christina est prête à suivre
votre shopping depuis son bureau
mode album de laura alors déjà un canton
rend dans une boutique on dit bonjour
welcome et 2 il est 18 heures on est
fermée merci bonne journée
eh ben tu veux dire au revoir kaunas
décidément de françoise vous récupérez
la lettre oui qu'aux secousses c'est au
pas par sa mère la [ __ ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]